welcome to the presentation on
subtracting decimal numbers let's get
some start let's get started with some
problems okay the first problem I have
here says five whoops five point I'm
reading out the problem off of a piece
of paper set five point seven three
minus point zero eight to one equals who
knows so the first thing you always want
to do with the decimal like this and I
actually kind of inadvertently did this
is that you want to line up the decimals
so you actually want this decimal to be
right above this decimal and I almost
did that when I did it it must have been
my subconscious doing it but let me just
do it a little bit neater so it's five
point seven three and then I'll put the
decimal here it's decimal zero eight two
one and some people I say it's good to
always put a zero in front of the
decimal my wife's the doctor and she
says it's critical otherwise you might
give someone the wrong amount of
medicine but anyway so we've lined up
the decimals and now we're ready to
subtract
so one thing that you have to think
about when you do decimals is we're
gonna have to subtract this this 21 ten
thousandths or this two and this one
from something we can't just subtract it
from from this blank space so we have to
add two zeros here and as you know with
the decimal when you add zeros to the
end of it it really doesn't change the
value of the decimal so at this point we
just view this like a level four
subtraction problem so the first thing
we do in any subtraction problems is see
if any of the numbers on top are smaller
than any of the numbers on the bottom
well in this case there are a lot of
them so this zero is less than this one
this zero is less than this 2 this 3 is
less than this 8 so we're going to have
to borrow and some people will like to
do their borrowing and subtracting they
kind of alternate between the two I like
to do all my borrowing ahead of time so
what I do is I start on the top right
and I say okay zero is less than one so
that zero becomes a ten
but in order to become a 10 I would have
had to borrow one from someplace I
looked to the left of that zero and say
well can I borrow the one from zero well
no this is just the way I do it there
are other people who would actually let
you borrow the one from the zero but I
say no instead of borrowing the one from
the zero I borrow the one from this
entire 30 so this 30 see right there's
this 3-0 so I'm going to borrow one from
it and it becomes 29 so we borrowed one
from this 30 to get a 10 here and now
let's check again to see if all of our
numbers on top are larger than all the
numbers on the bottom well 10 is larger
than 1 9 is larger than 2 2 is not
larger than 8 so we've got to borrow
again so if we're going to borrow the 2
becomes a 12 and the 7 we borrowed one
from that becomes a 6 so let's check
again 10 is larger than 1 9 is larger
than 2 12 is larger than 8 6 is larger
than 0 and 5 is larger than 0 so now
we've done all of our borrowing and
we're ready to do some subtraction and
this is the easy part
10 minus 1 is 9 9 minus 2 is 7 12 minus
8 is 4 6 minus 0 is 6 5 minus 0 is 5 and
we just bring down the decimal point so
there's our answer
5.7 3 minus 0.08 21 is equal to five
point six four seven nine there you go
I probably confused you so let's do some
more problems here's another one 8 to
leave some so you let me leave some
space on top to do the borrowing eight
point two five minus zero point
0-105 so what was that first step that I
always have to do right to line up the
decimal so let me do that so it's eight
point two five and zero point zero one
zero five notice I lined up this decimal
right below this decimal now I add the
zeros just because this is zero and this
five need to be subtracted from
something and now let me do my borrowing
so once again all I do is check to see
whether the top number is larger than
the number below it well this zero is
smaller than five someone have to borrow
so I'm going to borrow I can't borrow
from this zero I have to borrow from
this entire 50 so this 50 if I borrow
one from 50 I get 49 and this zero will
then become a ten right I borrowed one
from 50 to get a ten now am I done 10 is
larger than five nine is larger than
zero four is larger than one two is
larger than zero and eight is larger
than zero so I think I'm ready to
subtract ten minus five well that's five
nine minus 0 is 9 4 minus 1 is 3 2 minus
0 is 2 and 8 minus 0 is 8 and I bring
down the decimal point so if you
mastered level 4 subtraction the the
decimal problems really are just about
lining up the decimal point adding the
zeros and just doing a normal
subtraction problem in general with
subtraction I think most people have the
most trouble with the borrowing the way
I do it I think is a little bit
different that's taught in a lot of
schools a lot of schools they'll do the
subtraction they'll borrow alternatively
but I find this easier when I just
borrow ahead of time and I also like for
example in this problem when I had to
make this zero into a 10 instead of
borrowing from the zero which is not
intuitive because I can't really borrow
from zero
I borrowed from this entire 50 and I
made that into a 49 let's do one more
problem okay if I have two point six
four minus zero point zero zero four
eight six so once again let's line up
the decimal points two point six four
and it's point zero four eight six lined
up the decimal points add the zeros on
top it's going to have a zero here so I
have to borrow come to ten can't borrow
from the 0 so I have to borrow from this
entire 40 so this 40 becomes a 39 think
I'm running out of space so 10 is larger
than 6 9 is larger than 8 3 is not
larger than 4 so this 3 I'm going to
have to borrow so 3 becomes a 13 I
apologize I'm becoming squinched and the
6 becomes a 5 this is really bad I
shouldn't do it so messy but now we say
the 10 is larger than 6 the 9 is larger
than the 8 this 13 this 13 should be on
top of that 3 that 13 is larger than 4
and 5 is larger than 0 so we're ready to
subtract 10 minus 6 is 4 9 minus 8 is 1
13 minus 4 is 9 5 minus 0 is 5 2 minus
nothing is to bring down the decimal
point so 2 point 6 4 minus point zero 4
8 6 is equal to 2 point 5 9 1 4 hope I
didn't confuse you too much but I think
you're ready now to try the the
subtraction of decimals have fun